representa gráficamente la relación
proporcional que se muestra en la
siguiente tabla en esta tablita aquí
tenemos estos valores de x 0 3 6 9 y 12
y estos valores de y cuál es la
pendiente de la recta que representa
esta relación bueno antes que nada vamos
a graficar y notemos que cuando x vale 0
que también vale 0 por lo tanto puedo
colocar este punto en el 0 0 muy bien
ahora sólo tengo que poner cualquiera de
estos otros puntos en su ubicación
correcta vamos a hacer uno que tenga
coordenadas enteras por ejemplo cuando x
vale 6 que vale 1 entonces cuando x vale
6 llévale 1 ahí está el punto en el
lugar correcto así que esta es nuestra
recta pero bueno también nos preguntan
cuál es la pendiente de la recta que se
representa en esta relación o sea cuál
es la pendiente de esta recta pues
recuerden que nuestra pendiente la
pendiente una recta se define como el
alza entre el avance o lo que es lo
mismo el cambio en que para un cambio en
x dado o lo que es lo mismo
el cambio dividido entre el cambio en x
así que bueno si vamos de este punto a
este punto tenemos un cambio en de una
unidad nos saltamos una unidad y eso lo
dividimos entre el cambio en x que es de
6 unidades por lo tanto la pendiente
sería un sexto vamos a ponerlo un uy un
sexto
y vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta y
estamos en lo correcto